hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester we are back at the tata
steel Indian Edition Magnus Carlsen vs
Hikaru Nakamura so the leaders after day
1 face off in the first round of the
second day and it's a really crazy game
and it just really shows what incredible
positions Nakamura is able to play which
is just which is just very impressive so
without further ado let's check it out
and hopefully all of you have joined it
the tournament by now the stream is
today the tournament is today so I hope
I hope everyone can make it but more
information in the description below as
usual so without further ado Magnus
opens with C for the English opening is
on the board we have E 5 by Nakamura
Knight to c3 Knight to f6 Knight to f3
and Knight to c6 now the four Knights
are out and d3 this is the couple Blanc
of variation Magnus
often plays this we have d5 now
challenging the center C capture snide
captures and here just efore Magnus
already played this not long ago in the
st. Louis blitz theorem and the work he
played III against the ding and he won
one that again but here he advances the
point all the way so II for we have
Knight the F for Knights to b6 or Knight
to f6 are the two usual moves the one
would make here but McMurdo goes Knight
therefore and this has been attempted
only once so far and white won a very
nice game as white does a grab advantage
here just Bishop captures pawn captures
and now okay black now has the bishop
pair but white has a very strong center
now Carson advances the pawn to d4 and
there is a that one game where there we
mentioned the word Bishop to g4 whisper
but here Nakamura plays Bishop to d6 and
it is already as of move eight that we
have a completely new game so Crossan
plays h3 doesn't allow the bishop to be
developed to g4 nakamura castles and now
a3 so very instructive how across and
treats the position he has a excellent
piece pieces placement very very strong
central control here with his D and E
pawn
very natural development of pieces and
then he just improves the position with
h3 and a3 not not rushing
anything with a 6 by Nakamura and now
push up the c4 just an optimal square
for the bishop with King to h8 preparing
maybe f5 or f6 at some point and now II
five by Magnus pushing the bishop back
with Bishop to e7 and now even d5 so
this is uh this is a monster font center
here Knights the a5 attacking the bishop
and now bear should be back to a2 here
just nicely controlling the night and
the night all of the squares for the
night are now covered and if well if you
allow white to play before the night
will be trapped since there's no squares
for the night to retreat so b5 not
before ok at least you have the b7
square for the night with castles by
Magnus and now comes Nakamura has to do
something about the center so either
you're gonna challenge it with c6 not
right away because you'll face d6 so now
f6 that's why the King had to leave all
the way to h8 and now how do you deal
with this well first Magnus goes for B
for Kings denied all the way back well
not to c4 as now to b5 phone and guards
the c-4 square Bishop captures pawn
captures now there are two sets of
double points for black and now E six so
is if this if if if these bonds are not
too far advanced then this will be just
winning but nakamora will try to prove
that of course they are too far advanced
with Bishop to be 7 and now Queen to d4
by Magnus attacking both c4 and the f4
pawn it's time to collect some points
with c6 now and here Magnus starts
collecting them we have Queen captures
on c4 even though d6 was a possibility
but perhaps do-over
may be too adventurous of a move for a
rapid game because after the trades are
made here sorry captures captures now
rook a to d1 and now after the bishop
moves you get to bring the rook over to
the seventh rank which is definitely
worth upon and these double pawns are
very very likely to become targets in
the future so it should not be a problem
a very promising position for white but
ok Crossan starts collecting pawns we
have Queen captures and c4c captures on
d5 and now Queen captures on f4 we have
looked the c8 bringing the rook into the
game attacking
the night and see three and the night II
- now the night can now go maybe to d4 -
keep an eye on the on the east exponent
but also the night can come to f5 will
be an excellent square for the night so
brush up the d6 attacking the Queen and
Queen to e3 now keeping an eye on the
pawn here and a 5 here just getting rid
of that one pawn trying to create some
weaknesses here and of course the threat
is just a character son b4 which would
win win upon so we have night e - d for
getting the knight just into the game
and here rook to e8 you could capture
you could capture right away but if you
capture right away with a capture son
before in a capture son before the
bishop capture son before is not not all
that red because you just play rook to
b1 and now you will have problems here
it's not not at all clear how you will
be defending defending those bishops and
it's very easy to infiltrate for the
rook for example if Queen to e7 if you
try to defend the bishop this way Knight
the f5 just takes all of the important
squares from the Queen to guard that
should be good to go Queen to c5 but
then you just for example trade and then
you pick up the Bishop on b7 it's it's
too much - too many bishops on the B
file for you know for for black the
handle so here rook to e8 for Nakamura
and now comes Knight to f5 and excellent
square for the knight best back to b8
now if Nakamura can get some D for d3
action and then the bishop repair will
be will be in fact very strong so
Crossin has to be very careful we have
rook a to C 1 and now rook the c4 hoping
Magnus would trade and then you get a
nice pass c4 pawn here and also the
bishop pair now becomes deadly so Magnus
not interested in that he goes back with
the knight now adds another defender to
the pawn and now a capture Sun b4 with a
capture some before and here Nakamura
doesn't grab the point immediately first
he improves with Bishop to a 7 but
Magnus takes this opportunity to save
his spawn with b5 so probably capturing
the pond was the the way to go here and
now
just advances it we have Bishop to c5
now preparing to add another attacker to
the pin night here so Queen to d3 of
course you have to unpin Queen to b6 and
now rook captures on c4 now cross and
we'll win this point but Nakamura will
take care of the e6 pawn we have deke
Actress and c4 Queen captures and now
Bishop captures an f3 forcing White's to
recapture with the night because if you
recapture with the point you lose the
night here and you get rid of the
defender of the e6 pawn so Knight
captures an f3 and now just to rook
captures any six so now nakamura was
able to trade down however magnus still
has the past b5 point so is he able to
push it will just see we have g3 now
Magnus wants to get the king over 2 G 2
so the rook can move and then maybe even
at some lines you could sacrifice the f2
pawn but at least it will not come with
the check so rook to e8 getting the rook
well to e8 you want to bring it over to
bh to go after the b5 pawn and now kink
the g2 by Magnus and here Nakamura does
have some back rank issues so he should
continue with h6 leave the king some
reading room but Hiro Nakamura played
rook to b8 he went for the pawn
immediately and this just doesn't work
and this gives a white an opportunity to
play a wonderful move that will allow
him to continue pushing for the win so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure out which move this is
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a nice
move it's not an easy move to find and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's if you play rook the b1 we're
just gonna mention it yes you've got the
pawn but then you just give up the f2
point and now it's not gonna matter that
you have the beep on because now black
can even use the rook for attack it's
it's gonna be hard for whites to defend
this with the open King but if you find
Luke the c1 then congratulations that
move gives white all the time in the
world now you cannot capture as you will
lose the bishop here and you can't
really move the bishop anywhere so the
bishop doesn't control the f8 square for
example if you play something weird like
cap
nf2 now queen check is just winning
because if you capture you're getting
made it so you have to block with the
Queen but now you just trade and pick up
the bishop on if to your your upper
piece and you still have the past be
pawn so here Nakamura has to go back
push up the f8 but now you've you
regained control of the d4 square now
Knights the d4 and now you don't have to
use the roof to defend you can use the
roof to attack while the knight guards
the pawn here with h5 now now finally
making room for the king
so you don't have to worry about Bank
back rank issues anymore but now Knights
to e6
now again inviting Queen captures here
so you would get the rook away from the
back rank and then pick up the disappear
we have Bishop back to a 3 and the now
rook the c3 pushing the bishop back
Bishop to b4 and now Magnus just
straights but we have Queen captures
Queen captures and now rook the c5
attacking the h5 pawn we have Queen to
f7 defending and the now Queen to f4 REE
maneuvering the Queen to f3 to go after
the pond while attacking the rook on b8
so rook the d8 and now Queen to f3 just
attacking the pawn here so you have to
defended the g6 and now b6 now finally
Carlsen starts pushing the the passport
we have looked a d7 keeping an eye on b7
but rook the CH check with King to g7
and now Queen to c6 preparing rook to c7
if rook to c7 happens of course it's
game over since black doesn't really
have a way of preventing the pawn from
marching forward so we have Kings to h6
but now just H for my magnets not
allowing the King any squares we have f5
and here just
rook the c7 now that the position has
been improved as much as possible we
have Queen to d5 check now nakamura
trades Queens we have Queen captures
rook captures and now b7 we have looked
the b5 putting a room behind the passed
pawn which you should always do doesn't
matter if it's your pawn or your
opponent's pawn and here magnets just
played f4 and it was in this position
and move a 51 that he cannot come or
resigned the game and yet another
victory for Magnus Carlsen in round 4 of
the Tata Steel India rapid tournament so
here you resign because the black King
has no moves you can to go anywhere you
can just give some material by pushing
g5 the king is not allowed back on this
on the seventh rank and even if you try
rugby 3 to cut off the White King it
will not help you just king if - you're
gonna have to play a move with the rope
rook before the King III comes if rugby
three check you just bring the king
closer look b5 you just bring the King
core so rugby six you just bring the
King closer and at some point you're
gonna have to move the rook or King c6
you're gonna bring your King over here
Queen the pawn and win the game so it's
fairly straightforward and of course
both Nakamura and Magnus know this and
of course here not Nakamura resigned
swam that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Kenneth
deets unrest Booker and Scott McKay for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it and with his
contribution Scott McCain Scott McKay
joins the ranks of Sean Wilcox and and
David sacks as Todd contributors to the
channel so congratulations on that as
well
so like I said after I'm probably gonna
throw one more game from this rapid
event maybe maybe even two we'll see how
it goes and then we have to prepare
everything for the stream and and for
the well for the leeches arena and the
top seed at the moment that the
tournament is always a ferocious but you
know not everyone can win first place
but at least you may you may get the
chance to face earlier in this
tournament
I've also I've also seen partner and I
joined the tournament and some other
very strong grandmasters the penguin
joined and well but basically I've seen
at least 20 grand master so far but you
know it's still early three more hours
till the tournament a lot of people can
still join so the link to join the
tournament will also be in the
description below so you know I hope you
will be able to make it so thank you I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day